who is some run to the system she's  nobody  she doesn't exist no one remembers the  girl there were a thousand children like  her after the war but none of them could  hack like she could and she learned that  people were just as easily manipulated  now she understood how the world worked  information is power so she kept hacking  politicians corporations governments it  was an addiction but for the first time  someone noticed her when your hardware's  obsolete it's time to upgrade the girl  was gone and Sombra was born  now I'm ready  I'll find out who really runs the world  I'll find their weaknesses and how to  exploit them and when I do I'll be the  one pulling the strings  who is Sombra you'll never know Santos  you